I am so tired and I just want to give up
28 days I just let it go see beyond by
the end of this cube better lose weight
Kelsey better lose weight and our selfie
game better be on point right now I'm
still kind of trying to pin down one it
really works for me sometimes I'll go
back into boxing for like a month
sometimes I'll do stuff at the gym but I
really feel like I'm kind of just trying
to figure out what a good routine for me
I really do enjoy working out I've been
a very athletic person in my entire life
now the only issue is once you get a
little older and you have to start
working 40 hours a week you just have a
lot less time to go to the gym I feel
like Instagram models tend to try to
maintain a pretty decent physique
year-round I'm trying to find a fitness
and diet that works kind of more
long-term that might mean that I won't
see as much of a result but it will mean
that like I'll feel more confident doing
this challenge I really am looking
forward into getting back into great
shape and really getting that Instagram
model look at the end of this video I
want to eat that and I think that's a
crazy go to have but I want to set my
bar high so if I don't land on it I'm
still somewhere here baby and that's
good that's great
q and I have been put into contact with
a professional model fitness coach and
Instagrammer his name's Jeff Logan today
we're doing a 30 day challenge
q and Kelsey's gonna be training with me
on how to be a fitness model an
Instagram model he is like very
intimidating to be honest with you the
guy that we're working out with is
actually someone I know from my hometown
of Rochester New York my job is to look
good 24/7 it's the V photo ready video
ready 24/7 so I always have to be on
point I own four companies on my model I
axed my look is everything I have to be
on point all the time I'm either gonna
be really intimidated by him in the gym
and kind of scared or maybe he'll just
like
you that next boss level I train every
day twice a day sometimes three times a
day sometimes two training sessions and
a pool workout or sometimes my clients
that don't want to feel like they're
getting trained I have to train with
them so different times I'll train like
four times in a day who have you trained
so far that we might know just think
about the top celebrities think about a
thing about a thing about them I've
trained them taking all the top actors
I'm trainer most of my trainings I've
done in person with trainers so it's
hard for me to take it home and then
work on it myself and feel like oh I can
do this in the gym like I don't really
have a lot of gym confidence so the
workouts gonna be from our local
performance burn and shred program so
there's no excuses that's the thing
there's no excuses there's literally
video examples on what to do here we're
gonna be doing like full body work also
gonna be doing like Monday Wednesday
Friday full body upper body then full
body again and then in between those is
gonna be cardio really short fast bursts
of everything what kind of expectations
do you have for us I want to see a
physical change we're gonna get on the
scale today we're gonna take selfies
today yeah we're gonna take them on this
stuff yesterday you got the sport front
we're gonna fill you out of that shirt
and we're gonna see I want to see each
weekend and I got homework so each and
every week I'm gonna have them do one
challenge for Instagram to show the
progress that we've been getting and I'm
gonna know if they're working or not
because I have to say if you ain't
driven you're tripping so if you're
pretty much if you're not sweating
during the workout you're not doing
nothing
I want results I don't know anything
except results yeah I'm kind of nervous
about that you should be nervous you
guys are gonna skip right to the
Advanced section are you ready let's do
it let's do this come on come on come on
come on come on the first weigh-in I
wasn't sure what I was gonna be looking
like I know I was a lot over mud usually
I don't even get on a scale in front of
myself anymore like a lot of people I
feel like I get really hung up on the
number and that number kind of decreases
my value
times in my brain and I really hate that
they both looked at the scale and they
didn't like it so it's on me now the
pressures on me we set the goal to kind
of like drop about probably like six or
seven pounds so I gotta make sure hey I
give you the fat burners I give you the
program I give you the motivation so now
when you go do a buck by yourself you
have no excuse cause like that's a lot
of pressure on me because next time you
company we gotta get on the scale and
when it's scale has to be lowered so I
got to make sure they're covered on
every angle and there's no questions so
[Music]
this was a full body workout like having
a new pull-ups I could barely do the
work you know it was tough what was
great about Jeff is that everything was
pretty accessible yeah it was hard work
but it wasn't things that I didn't feel
like I could manage like I always felt
confident of like oh I kind of been
familiar with that move here's a
variation of it that I can do to
challenge myself a little bit more Jeff
was also just so nice going into it I
was actually really intimidated by Jeff
especially on his Instagram but he's
actually the nicest funniest human
that's like incredibly warm in person it
just great to be around
so his energy was infectious immediately
he realized okay this is from Rome we're
doing like four or five sets of like
2015 ten I mean honestly just doing four
sets of anything is a lot for me Jeff is
a very serious guy he took the work I
was very seriously and the workouts were
in and I thought like Kelsey felt the
same way I feel like wouldn't we left
there we both were like okay we gotta
get serious
it was a really tough workout I was
definitely sore pretty much walking out
the door so to see that I was okay look
I know if I want to get this a pack if I
want to really shut up I have to go
really hard and I have to follow this
dive
down to a tee it's time to take the
infamous post-workout self because you
can't take a pre-workout selfie because
you're not pumped up yet the blood is
not through your muscles you haven't
worked out you didn't do anything
yep pants all right you post it so the
next one you post has to be better
that's pressure on you
it says stop chewing gum flex mm-hmm
go yourself right there put day one save
that from the curb show them the curves
three two one boom and not we just broke
Instagram and now we gotta do a group
selfie group selfie three two I don't
think there was anything wrong with my
first selfie day one with Jeff is done
he definitely worked me hard but I also
really enjoyed it everything was very
accessible but challenging I'm tardy
sore I'm hoping for like a mental
makeover as well as a physical one gains
in the brains and in the hope that you
know that joke didn't land trying to get
those gains but also with my brains you
know
nope it got worse but week one was
pretty tough I honestly thought that I
was going to be able to do the stuff
that he does the workouts at home were
even worse the first week because when
I'm working all by myself personally
it's really hard to stay motivated to
like to be on a 12 rep but you have 15
to go
you know I'm tired like I just don't
want to finish it but when I'm working
out with Jeff he's like get it up let's
go let's go you got this one more my
entire body
[Music]
it's only been two days it's finally
Saturday so tomorrow I finally get a day
off and it was a long time but I was
very impressed with the fact that I
could kind of keep going and it's like
wow then I got to the ALF workouts and I
just started dying I think it all caught
up to me
I've never taken pre-workout before
really so it's like a new experience I'm
like shaking because this workout my
face is bright red so they're gonna be
taking be lean be clean be multi and
again these are all stuff that I created
so there's no excuse to so by the end of
this Q better lose weight Kelsey better
lose weight and our selfie game better
be on point it's finished day to a party
oh I didn't even do an address and I'm
tired and I'm really sorry on what I
signed up for 28 days week wine I didn't
change my diet that much week 1 to be
quite honest but my diets already pretty
much I like eat whole foods for diet let
me tell you what we're not gonna do
we're not gonna cheat we're not gonna
eat red meat we're gonna try to stay
away from chicken we're gonna stay away
from processed food this is a program
that I personally do I wrote it
these are supplements that I take so I
wouldn't ever ask them anything that I
don't do it was a really hard first week
it definitely made me feel like I was
out of shape I didn't think I was that
out of shape before this process but
apparently I kind of was stay six I went
out for breakfast and I grabbed the oat
meal from McDonald's with like the
raisins and apples and all that good
stuff unfortunately I also grab like
this McGriddle little 2 for 3 deal I
know that's not on the nutrition list
I gotta feel that it's not it's week 2
it's Monday I'm just like not in the
mood this morning but I'm doing it
anyway which are very proud of
so week two I finally decided to reach
out for more clarification from Jeff
about what I should be eating so we're
not gonna be doing cheap bills we're not
gonna be too fast we're not gonna be
eating at the famous hamburger place or
french fries limit we're gonna be doing
lean cuts of meat this sort of the car
can help the best you've got to stay
away from anything saturated fat
definitely stay with the transplant you
think processes hours
so if week to the workouts got easier
but the diet got harder how you doing
can I get a number two no the Baconator
milk
making horrible decisions it's gonna be
way hard not the [ __ ] he big news I want
shot him it is my last one it's like
it's kind of deep into the challenge to
be Sean EPS but once I managed my last
one he gave us some vegan whey protein
which I thought was really cool for him
not to be vegan but to have a vegan whey
protein was pretty interesting this and
avoid too
I feel like I've already kind of noticed
some difference there's definitely been
a lot less water weight and bloating
this week which has been really nice but
these workouts are still killing me I'm
still sore pretty much every day working
on solo though easy okay
so decided we agreed we popped it off at
the weigh-in we wanted to see where we
were for midway through our 30-day
challenge honestly I felt pretty good I
think at that point I had dropped at
least 5 to 6 pounds which is pretty like
impressive for just that short amount of
times I'm like dude if you wouldn't hate
that burger and if you didn't you know
grab a beer that one night that would
have been more you know so that really
pushed me to be like okay focus do your
best to get the best results it's midway
through the training there's only two
weeks left and I'm feeling fantastic I'm
really enjoying it I'm enjoying what I'm
doing do I look like a model like no but
like they do this for their job they do
this for their whole lives you know so
it'd be kind of like ridiculous to
compare me even if I've started with
like a little bit of a fitness
background and also I'm like dripping
sweat this is fun
working out got a little salmon salad
trying to keep it healthy I've messed up
a lot lately but I'm nudists
we're down you're down we are being Lena
2019 it was a high 135 I'm like a proud
train the right way down so we're the
finest Hudson is trying to like that his
grandmother for 30 days finally I feel
and I've got my daddy new there so it's
a week for Jeff suggested that we start
cutting things and adding some things to
help kind of like the transformation he
said like a lot of times before a shoot
he'll do something like this where he'll
cut all carbs it wasn't too bad and I
definitely was excited because I was
seeing results and I was thinking you
know like there was some moments I saw
us on the mirror like dang I cut and I
was confident and proud because I didn't
feel like I was sacrificing my whole
well-being to do it I was more like
enhancing my well-being and so it was a
really fun week day 28
I had a really off weekend but today I
came hard
how'd it go harness gym the workouts are
still killing me every time which is
10/10 um I can feel like I am getting
stronger I do feel like I've been leaner
in general with less bloating and things
like that because the diet's been so
clean I feel like the favorite thing
that I learned for this process is that
I can jump up and do it the attack
Burpee know is really proud of myself
for that today is the day we're gonna
get the final weigh-in so we have to see
if everything worked I mean it look like
it what it does what it does I can't
control it it looked like it worked I
mean I'm looking at their bodies and
their body composition so from Kelsey
the first thing I notice is her back the
back muscles are just like oh and I'm
just like girl look at your back and
she's like yeah whatever and our video
dinner show just like oh [ __ ] my back
cut and then cue took a shirtless selfie
and we put it side by side with his
first pick and people were claiming the
Photoshop that's what whoa yeah a
Photoshop come on yeah so yeah let's hop
on the scale and see the results yeah
damn damn yeah good [ __ ]
this is are you shocked you took you did
everything right
I think it's more like I didn't feel at
any point like like I was dying for it I
was happy the whole time right it was
like fun what do we start at so we lost
like what 20 pounds yeah ma you like I
can see your lines your stomach was out
your face was bigger it was yeah yeah
how you are right now no three high five
I think I found a good balance for me
Jeff was fantastic the whole way and I'm
definitely gonna be probably sticking to
this routine for the foreseeable future
me and Kelsey both dropped about 10
pounds apiece which is crazy like I feel
like the results spoke for themselves we
worked hard we trained the best we could
we got the results we wanted which is
great that's always great
[Music]